слово Володимиру арієву з інформацією з
погоджувальної
ради Слава
Україні а
нічого нового не
відбулося лише європейська Солідарність
і голос на погоджувальній Раді з усіх
фракцій вимагали створення тимчасової
слідчої комісії по зраді на найвищому
рівні всі інші заховали голову в пісок
на сьогоднішній день лише три фракції
Верховної Ради України дали своїх
представників в тимчасову слідчу комісію
це європейська Солідарність голоси
батьківщина всі інші ховають голову в
пісокба це ганьба
це співучасть у зраді
Я думаю що вони нас почують тому що я
сьогодні буду звертатися до вас як той
хто частину матеріалів оприлюднив і взяв
певний вогонь на
себеєє
Дякуємо у нас справа не закінчена Тому я
прошу кожного з вас кожного хто є тут
хто дивиться трансляцію
звідси а ви прийдіть до народних
депутатів із фракції слуга
народу Ну до опзж нема чого ходити до
слуг народу до
фракцій за майбутнє і
довіра пишіть їм і питайте кожного разу
Де ваша позиція по
ТСК вимагайте від них щоб вони припинили
покривати
злочинців тому що сьогодні на кону
безпека країни тому що ми маємо розуміти
що в найвищих органах влади в найвищ
біля найвищого кабінету держави а
можливо і всередині найвищого кабінету
держави є
зрадник І цього зрадника треба показово
покарати ми маємо зрозуміти що якщо
цього не буде ми маємо вимагати
відставки президента України і
імпічмента за те що він сьогодні
покриває злочинців так само як покриває
Голова Верховної Ради разумков який
робить вигляд що Нічого не
відбувається
ганьбагань імпічмен
імпічмен
імпічмен імпічмен
[музика]
імчмен
імчмен і я вважаю що сьогодні у нас лише
початок боротьби тому що ми бачимо
абсолютне небажання влади розуміти всю
серйозність ситуації мало того ми бачимо
бажання переслідувати тих хто повідомив
про крота в найвищих органах влади ми
будемо іти до кінця і ми будемо до того
моменту поки ми не дізнаємося правду і
якщо тимчасово слідча комісія не буде
створена ми маємо переходити до
постійних акцій протесту ми будемо іти
по-серйозному на захист інтересів
України як йшли з 2014 року і не
припиняли жодної хвилини європейська
Солідарність з тими хто захищав
батьківщину і буде в інтересах тих діяти
хто втратив своїх рідних І хто сьогодні
вимагає Правди Слава Україні Героям
слава разом сила Разом друзі слово
надається
координатору громадського об'єднання
безпеки та взаємодії в Україні Семену
кабакаєву друзі Добрий день я радий всіх
сьогодні бачити Дуже багато облич
знайомих володярв дуже багато вже сказа
ви знаєте Я погоджуюсь з ним Тому що
людина яка сидить в офісі президента є
російським кротом ми це з вами розуміємо
прекрасно але я хотів би сказати як
зараз відносяться до нас слуги народа і
ті хто сидіть сидить в офісі президента
і Ярмак і всі інші хто формує порядок
денний безпосередньо Володимиру
зеленському Вони думають що ми маргінали
які походимо розійдемось і просто треба
ігнорувати цю проблему і вона сама
розсмокчиться Я хочу передати їм
користуючись можливістю що ні не
розсмокчиться я розумію що для більшості
українців не зрозуміло як ця справа може
впливати на їх повсякденне життя тому що
якщо десь там щось в Білорусі відбулось
хтось комусь щось розповів ну це не
впливає на холодильник там або на ще
щось я хочу сказати що впливає тому що
якщо люди які сидять там спочатку
передають інформацію потім запрошують їх
сюди в Київ Такі як Кравчук покін що
вони казали що Ми запрошуємо маріонеток
Путіна сюди в в Київ а потім ми будемо
розмовляти їхати до нис якщо вони не
приїдуть сюди то це є зрада національних
інтересів держава більше 13 000 наших
людей загинуло на фронті не для того щоб
маріонеток Путіна сюди запрошували не
для того щоб ми зливали інформацію
Російській Федерації не для того того
щоб люди які зараз тримають владу в
своїх кишенях сиділи і розповідали нам
ті хто виборював цю незалежність на
фронті на Майдані як ми будуватимемо
нашу державу не вони будуть вирішувати
цей порядок денний ми з вами будемо
вирішувати я вас закликаю для до більш
радикальних дій якщо вони не розуміють
такі протести ми перенесемо шини ми
будемо палити ми будемо зривати
засідання Верховної Ради ми не дамо
працювати офісу президента ми не дамо
щоб відбулась зрада національних
інтересів держави друзі тому ми будемо
оголошувати на сторінки руху Оперу
капітуляції на сторінках наших в
Фейсбуці Слідкуйте Ми запрошуємо вас на
наступні акції
Дякую друзі ситуація така ще триває
засідання погоджувальної Ради йде
дискусія якщо ми розійдемось швидше Ну
буде просто несерйозно з нашого боку
тобто ми повинні цю сторінку з ТСК з
погоджувальною радою пройти до кінця
прочитати її до кінця ще одне тут зараз
будете забігати ці зелені миші на
прес-конференцію прошу там з цього боку
периметр дивитися якщо ви бачите там
вишикувались камери то Якщо є то давати
сигнал щоб вони почули нашу думку також
зрозумійте правильно ми повинні пройти
цей шлях парламентської боротьби для
чого Ми повинні його прийти він нудний
Він не є такий яскравий але для чого для
того щоби уже все інше про яке говорив
Семен І те що ми готуємо на майбутнє
тобто методи боротьби більш
позапарламентські більш вуличні і рішучі
для нас були вже легітимними ми пройдемо
спочатку цей сценарій парламентський ТСК
процедура імпічмента хоча б її старт а
дальше ми будемо наші дії будуть
легітимними в очах і громадськостіі цієї
і цивілізованого світу коли ми перейдемо
до більш жорстких методів приведення до
притомності цієї влади А ще точніше до
деокупації України Бо Україна де-факто
уже окупована і нам треба боротись за її
звільнення прошу Сашко
продовжую Дякуємо А зараз запрошую до
слова
депутата депутата європейської
солідарності Миколу величковича
шановні шановні друзі Ми тільки що з
Володимиром арієвим вийшли з
погоджувальної ради там озву було
озвучено стояло питання про створення
ТСК вимога
щоби тимчасова слідча комісія могла
працювати Ми навіть вимагали тему щоби
було
закрите наш Ірини грещенко ставила
питання щоби навіть провести закритий
засідання Верховної Ради заслухати
президента і ті всі питання які
стосуються цієї зради в офісі президента
роомков проігнорував Так тихенько знаєте
Він завжди любить деколи коментувати а
тут просто промовчав і жодного слова
коментаря просто прослухав і зразу зразу
забрав слово для інших Це значить що
вони цього бояться але ми завтра в
Верховній Раді не дамо їм це промовчати
і будемо жорстко вимагати щоби це СК
стояло На порядку денному і було
включено Я сподіваюся що суспільство
громадянське суспільство повинно
допомогти нам в цьому маєте можливість
спілкуватися з якимись депутатами
питайтеся їхню позицію чи вони будуть
голосувати за створення ТСК тільки разом
ми можемо цього добитися інакше вони
будуть робити все щоби цього уникнути бо
вони цього бояться вони бояться тому що
ця зрада їм не
пройде український народ не повинен
цього випускати і ті хто це зробив
повинен понести відповідальність тому
закликаю вас маєте змогу звертатися до
депутатів усіх
питається їхню позицію як вони будуть
голосувати за ТСК як вони будуть
підтримувати Тому що тільки таким тиском
ми можемо їх заставити це підтримати Ми
повинні
підтримати родини загиблих наших воїнів
які створили цю петицію Не політики а
родини загиблих воїнів створили цю
петицію і тому повинен усі незалежно від
політичної орієнтації натиснути на цих
депутатів від більшості щоби була
проголосована тимчасова слідчу комі а
далі а далі буде І вони понесуть
відповідальність Слава Україні
Слава друзі схоже на те що попри нашу
присутність депутати Верховної Ради нас
не чують Давайте зробимо і візуально і
звуком Щоб нас
[музика]
почули
ТСК ТСК
ТСК ТС
ТСК цс
ЦСКА ЦСКА
ЦСКА
b b
b
[музика]
к
сск
СК
СК СК
к
ДК ДСК
СК
к
[музика]
Пропустіть будь ласка спецтранспорт і
громадський транспорт друзі обережно їде
автобус і спецтранспорт за
[музика]
ним
ро род ро
[музика]
бакать
ç
ш
ще ро
ророй я
[музика]
покарай
ди
[музика]
ро
родний
край
[музика]
Я питаю
зараз Слава
Україні Слава друзі Ви знаєте я отак
дивлюсь Вони думають що вони завше
будуть ігнорити але ми знаємо що народні
депутати України частина з них живе тут
в готелі Київ ми знаємо де вони живуть Я
думаю що не гріх же ж прийти до депутата
додому і спитатися ти за ТС чи ти проти
ТСК тому я рекомендую зеленим депутатам
готуватися до те що ми будемо до них
ходити в гості якщо є громадяни України
які дивляться цю передачу Можливо по
телевізору чи по фейсбуку Я закликаю ви
знаєте що у вас по сусідству є депутат
Зайдіть до нього в гості викладіть стрім
хай він на весь світ скаже каже він за
ТСК чи він проти ТСК він за Україну чи
він за Україну Коломойського він за
Україну для громадян України чи він за
Україну Зеленського Який такий самий як
і Коломойський в нас сьогодні в нас ще є
зараз нова партія за майбутнє
Коломойського тому я вас закликаю Якщо є
можливість і хтось знає де живе народний
депутат піймай з депутата Спитай в нього
по-нормальному поки що Дякую Слава
Україні Слава
[музика]
[оплески]
бачиш
по зава
[оплески]
[музика]
свої має більшість людей
по і небесде покличимо себе всі зби чами
ї життя
роби друзі нас Ірина
грещенко так друзі зараз підходить до
закінчення засідання погоджувальної Ради
ну вийшли депутати Ірина Геращенко і
Івана
ндзе зараз вони повідомлять
новини шановні друзі Дорогі колеги на
погоджувальній раді наша фракція
європейської солідарності
продемонструвала всім присутнім там ось
ці підписи
підписи
Мам вдів доньок синів сестер братів
загиблих наших героїв з вимогою взяти до
уваги їх позицію і негайного створення
ТСК з вагнерівців власне ми бачимо що
все це ланцюги одного такого ціпка який
сьогодні стає політикою діючої влади вже
рік Влада не ставить на погоджувальні
попри наші вимоги до порядку денного
створення ТСК у справі Шеремета і
сфальсифікована справа проти ветеранів
знаходиться ми бачимо в судилищі так
само вже 10 днів є вимога наша наших
колег по демократичній опозиції
громадянського суспільства негайного
створення ТСК але подали своїх
кандидатів до цієї ТСК тільки
європейська Солідарність тільки голос і
Батьківщина я запита А де депутатські
групи де Довіра де Майбах ну від опзж ми
не чекаємо нічого але ж де слуги народу
кому Вони служать І взагалі як може таке
бути що керівництво парламенту яке
безпосередньо за ручку разумком привів
Зеленського до влади був його говорящий
головой під час виборчої кампанії зараз
мовчить про події в Білорусі Зараз
мовчить про ТСК коли оці дедушки внучки
і жучки вимагають привести вже бойовиків
на позиції нашої армії зараз він мовчить
насправді так само про те що здається
наші позиції в нормандському форматі
друзі Я працювала в Мінській групі
чотири роки я хочу сказати що знаю які
це важкі переговори і тоді вся країна
знала імена політв'язнів сінсов сущенка
кольченка Балух який вже тиждень лежить
без свідомості в комі в лікарні і
невідомо хто його побив А хто зараз ці
політв'язні Кремля де їх прізвища Просто
100 людей нам говорять
безімянних тому що насправді дуже
змінилась позиція не тільки влади а
змінилась позиція олігархічних медіа
якім не цікаві зараз прізвища
політв'язнів Кремля заручників на
окупованих територіях якім не цікаві
долі їх родин і ось ця Влада вона блокує
ТСК по вагнерівцям закон про статус
політв'язнів які ми в першому читанні
прийняли закон про військових капеланів
а ддушки внучок і жучок які на початку
90-х здали ядерну зброю здали
Чорноморський флот і Чорноморське
пароплавство сьогодні здають країну ми
цього не допустимо і я хочу подякувати
кожному хто прийшов сьогодні вимагати
від Верховної Ради згадати що наш голос
має звучати в питаннях зовнішньої
політики поряд зі мною Іванка
климпуштинсадзе яка була першою жінкою
віце-прем'єркою з євроатлантичної
інтеграції і не було жодної міжнародної
зустрічі де незвучала тема безпеки тема
санкцій проти російської федерації
гуманітарні питання і вимоги до Росії а
сьогодні все винна Україна ми винні
Росії писати закони за сценаріями козака
і Путіна ми винні Росії політичний блок
Мінських угод А де безпековий де
гуманітарний це питання тут до нашої
влади і власне наша фракція вимагає не
тільки постанови по вагнерівцям ми
вимагаємо закритого засідання Верховної
Ради де має звітувати Зеленський про те
що відбувається з країною про те крок за
кроком Вона здається Вибачте він рік
тому тут сидів зранку до вечора байки
розказував де він зараз не треба
ховатися треба прийти і звітувати Що
відбувається на фронті що відбувається в
міжнародній політи
що відбувається у внутрішній
політиці дорогі друзі шановне товариство
насамперед хочу подякувати кожному з вас
за вашу активну і небайдужу позицію тому
що ми безпосередньо як європейська
Солідарність Будемо продовжувати
боротьбу за країну за нашу безпеку в
стінах парламенту але ми точно тепер
розуміємо і знаємо що ми маємо На кого
опертися і поза стінами парламенту і
наше це наша спільна боротьба за те щоби
Влада перестала нарешті наближатися не
просто переходити а наближатися до
червоних ліній тому що насправді ми
дійсно відчуваємо як по всіх фронтах
країну всередині штовхають у хаос А на
зовнішньополітичній арені країна
перестала мати позицію країна мимрить
Ніхто з наших партнерів вже не розуміє а
Власне кажучи чи Україна сама наполягає
на тому щоби відновити свою
територіальну цілісність суверенітет і
незалежних незалежність на умовах дійсно
міжнародного права чи Україна просто
готова виконувати будь-які забаганки які
приходять з Кремля бо так звучать
сьогодні ті очільники які ведуть
перемовини від імені України чи то в
нормандському форматі чи то в Мінській
сторонній контактній групі і кожного дня
ми з вами чуємо як закидається нові і
нові пробні шари чи проковтне
суспільство ще чергову подачку і ще
чергову зраду на користь Путіна і я
вдячна що ми не даємо спільно не даємо
все-таки ці не заглотуємо оці наживки я
не заковтуємо ціі наживки які кидає весь
час Влада ось уже втретє в стінах
парламенту за останні два тижні
намагаються тим чи іншим способом
провести законопроект який
дозволяє проводити якісь міфічні
опитування в день виборів і ми розуміємо
що ці міфічні опитування будуть
використані і для маніпуляції виборчими
результатами на на всій території
України і для того щоби створити
підґрунття для виконання оцих вимог
Росії для того щоби зараз стрім голов
незважаючи на відсутність безпекового
компоненту незважаючи на невиконання
Росією жодного взагалі жодної вимоги
мінських домовленостей проводити вибори
під дулами автоматів Ми бачили так звані
референдуми в Криму під під автоматами
зелёных человечков це те що сьогоднішня
Влада хоче провести на окупованому
Донбасі ми цього в стінах парламенту
рішення не допустимо але дуже
розраховуємо на те що ми спільно будемо
стояти проти порушення цих червоних
ліній Дякую вам схоже за все друзі схоже
за все закінчилася погоджувальна рада Я
думаю що дуже важливо щоби ті фракції
які досі не дали своїх представників до
тристорон до не тристоронньої контактної
групи А до тимчасової слідчої комісії
почули голос громади голос
парламентських партій голос
позапарламентських партій Ми дякуємо тут
нашим союзникам з Дем сокири іншим
позапарламентським партіям які так само
стоять на демократичних позиціях і цю
вимогу неможливість зради української
армії неможливість зради загиблих воїнів
ми маємо насправді давати дуже чесні
відповіді що сьогодні відбувається на
фронті що сьогодні відбувається Так само
назовні І от Знаєте до чого домовились
Не погоджуваня що має прийти в п'ятницю
віце-прем'єр з питань деокупації Олексій
Резнік але як людина яка працювала в
тристоронній контактній групі я хочу
сказати там немає самодіяльності там
Геращенко і всі інші виконували чіткі
директиви Порошенка а Порошенко давав
одну директиву звільнення наших
територій захист територіальної
цілісності і суверенітету і жодного
жодної жодного взагалі послаблення цих
наших вимог тому немає там ніяких знаєте
екзерсистів Кравчука чи цього Фокіна
джучки і внучки А там є виключно
директиви Зеленського і це мають бути до
нього вимоги звільнення жучик і внучик і
їх дедушек і насправді захист
територіальної цілісності і суверенітету
України ні кроку назад і давайте
згадаємо що за ці півтора роки
Зеленського жодного сантиметру
української землі не звільнено в той же
час військові визнають що бойовики
кипають уже свої копи вглуб українських
територій ну що це таке відбувається
кожен метр кожен метр скрапле ро
українських військових нам знаєте що
говорять сьогодні опзж на погоджувальній
так в серпні ж ніхто не загинув А п'ять
загиблих один від снайпера а інший від
Міна які були скинуті з літальних цих
Дронів Скажіть мені будь ласка якщо в
Зеленського в голові війна Закінчилася
чи це означає що вона закінчилась
очевидно що ні війна закінчиться Коли
український прапор буде стояти в
Донецьку Луганську війна закінчиться
коли ми отримаємо під наш контроль наш
кордон а все інше знаєте це якісь
абсолютна маячня яка не піддається
аналізу і це вже не Геращенко говорить
не арієв ні Іванка климпушнсадзе це ж
говорить людина яка привела Зеленського
за ручку до влади разом з каналом 1+1
Товарищ Богдан який за ручку його завів
на банкову говорить що це все правда так
будь ласка якщо це правда давайте нехай
дадуть тоді цьому оцінку компетентні
органи а не щоби отут така відбувалася
ганьба це є наша вимога дякую
Дякуємо друзі я так зрозумів з виступу
народних депутатів звичайно ж вони не
призначили ТСК ні по вагнерівцях ні по
шереметах Ані вони будуть подавати до
суду подавати законопроект про
ліквідації окружного адміністративного
суду тому
друзі те що ми сьогодні тут стояли Це
було дуже важливо Дякую вам всім
Але що ми будемо робити
далі що ми будемо робити
далі є наступна пропозиція до депутатів
Верховної Ради як наступний крок тому я
зараз зачитаю наші пропозиції і
вимоги сьогодні на погоджувальній раді
Верховної Ради України депутати
відмовилися розглядати вимоги акції
правди не сховаєш зокрема створювати ТСК
у справі
вагнерівців ТСК щодо фальсифікації у
справі вбивства Павла Шеремета у зв'язку
з тим що Верховна Рада не виконує свої
обов'язки як контролюючий орган ми
Закликаємо депутатів які стоять на
державницьких проукраїнських позиціях
зокрема фракції голосу європейської
солідарності
батьківщини позафракційних депутатів і
частину фракції слуги народу які
все-таки не зрадили державі заблокувати
роботу парламенту до тих пір поки наші
вимоги не будуть
виконані така Верховна Рада не має
працювати вона вже не
працює вимоги наші наступні я нагадаю
створити тимчасову слідчу комісію щодо
розслідування фактів здачі національних
інтересів та Державної зради в діях
посадових осіб у справі
вагнерівців заслухати звіт Міністрів
оборони та закордонних справ
представників тристоронньої контактної
групи голови СБУ та командування
збройних сил щодо ситуації з так званим
перемир'ям та спільними з представниками
так званого ДНР інспектуванням позицій
збройних сил
України створити тимчасову слідчу
комісію Верховної Ради щодо
фальсифікації справи вбивства Павла
Шеремета та відповідних експертиз у ній
зокрема розглянути проект постанови
Верховної Ради України про звернення
президента України щодо внесення до
Верховної Ради України проекту закону
про ліквідацію окружного
адміністративного
суду і на останок важливо Запрошуємо всі
політичні партії громадські рухи до
створення єдиного координаційного штабу
спротиву державній зраді реваншу та
капітуляції ми пропонуємо
ми пропонуємо спільно готувати акції
громадянської непокори з метою
дострокового припинення пчмент імпчмент
чмент
імпчмент
імпічмент
імпічмен
ічмен друзі друзі Ми відкладати дуже не
будемо з нашими наступними діями тому що
це буде Знов яккажуть прийшли поговорили
розійшлись ми бачимо що парламентські
методи зараз не дуже
працюють Звичайно що ми хочемо для того
щоб наші дії були сильними Нам потрібні
всі
Шкода що тут бу була тільки
євросолідарність я вам наперед скажу що
ми запрошували формально і неформально і
фракцію голос і фракцію Батьківщина і
всіх інших які є патріотичними силами чи
принаймні так себе позиціонують з тим
щоби діяти спільно знаєте того той час
коли ділитися по партійній приналежності
такий важливий для країни момент це є
гріх і абсурд тому що ми з тими не
вийдемо бо це парахабо
А ті говорять з тими не вийдемо бо вони
там ще якісь ну це абсурд якщо ми любимо
Україну якщо ми проти Москви і проти
цієї влади капітулянтів треба діяти
спільно Тому цей тиждень ми присвятимо
формуванню єдиного штаба єдиного центру
спротиву просимо вас всіх вас тиснути на
своїх партійних лідерів з тим щоб вони
на якийсь час зняли з себе з голови
корони перестали мірятися рейтингами
перестали мірятись короби бочками як це
було 24 серпня те що ми десь дійсно одні
пішли на концерт другі десь розійшлися
взагалі так ми повинні яко єдиний
спільний кулак виступити вдарити по цій
Владі і перемогти це єдиний рецепт нашої
Перемоги Тому цього тижня всі наші
зусилля мають бути кинуті на формування
спільного штабу опору реваншу
капітуляції та державній зраді і
вимагайте від цих вождів наших щоби вони
швидше прокидалися сну знімали корони і
почали працювати Тому друзі Я думаю що
наша наступна дія буде оголошена в
найближчий період але для цього нам
потрібні консультації зі всіма
попереджаю одразу що всі запрошення
тепер будуть публічними для всіх
політичних сил правила проведення будуть
прозорими щоб не було яких спекуляції що
це чийсь партійний мітинг чи чиясь
партійна агітація знаєте є час для
агітації це вибори будь ласка проводьте
собі вибори агітуйте є час для боротьби
рух опору капітуляції Це не про вибори
не про рейтинги А про боротьбу з режимом
окупантів тому друзі Дякую що ви прийшли
разом сила разом сила разом сила разом
сила разом сила разом сила до уваги йде
автобус до
уваги пропускаємо громадський транспорт
СК
ТСК
ТСК дтск
ТС ТС
ТС ПС
Я зараз т
т Друзі на
заверше
украї
єла Україна поду все Україна поду все